staggering new numbers on the border
crisis as the white house now admits
its own policies may in fact be driving
the migrant surge
i'm harris faulkner you are in the
faulkner focus and we are closely
watching
that dire situation of child migrants
streaming across our southern border
into the united states
the biden team is now reportedly
desperate to find places
to house them they're looking at unused
school buildings military bases and even
a nasa facility
and the white house southern border
coordinator is not denying
that biden's policies play a role in the
surge and are encouraging smugglers to
be bolder
than ever we've seen surges before
surges tend to respond to hope
and there was a significant hope
for a more humane policy after
four years of you know pent up demand
so i don't know whether i would call
that a coincidence but i certainly think
that
the idea that a more humane policy would
be in place
may have driven people to make that
decision
well here's how many are coming more
than 100
000 migrants were encountered at the
border
in february that's a 97
jump from the same month of last year
nearly 30 000 unaccompanied children
were encountered some 3 000
of them 12 years old or younger
arrests and deportations also plunged as
president biden tightened the rules on
how ice agents can operate
there were more than 2300 arrests in
february
that's down 66 percent from the average
number over october
november and december and only about
half the number of deportations in
february compared to the month before
so we are headed in that direction fewer
people
stopped at the border or elsewhere who
are here illegally
republicans from border states are going
after the biden white house over this
cartels have operational control of our
border and the biden administration
knows it
and they don't care what are you going
to do
about this catastrophe it is a
humanitarian crisis
stop spending your time cow towing to
the radical left
take ownership of this crisis that
you've created step up
and help us fix this you would have to
have the most acute case
of suspended reality to deny that we
have
a border crisis
ken cuccinelli former acting dhs
secretary a key player in former
president
trump's border security strategy is with
me now ken thank you for being here
so this is unfolding now before our eyes
at a much more rapid pace
uh and and i hear democrats saying oh
well this happens all the time well why
didn't it happen last
year what really specifically is being
driven
by biden policies yeah it does not
happen all the time that's a ludicrous
statement
and and part of the reason they're
trying so desperately to play this down
and to avoid using the word crisis is
that joe biden
is personally responsible for this
he is personally responsible for this he
invited them to come
illegally what you just heard jacobsen
call a more
humane policy what they mean is we won't
enforce the law
that's what they mean and they have
broadcast that across the world
and the world is responding just as they
expected it to
and at the same time they're
stopping deportations so anybody who
comes illegally knows they're not going
to be sent home
and they're reenacting catch and release
so it's really just a hello mr border
patrol agent nice to see you
i'll just move on to chicago to new york
to virginia
to iowa whatever and that frankly
they're turning their transportation
resources
not to returning deporting people but to
moving them farther into our own country
so this is uh they have brought this on
themselves and they're facilitating it
and can we've seen uh you know bus
companies we've seen
people who are responsible for transport
saying we need negative covid
19 tests when these people get on buses
i mean they're fanning out and that's
the adults
the situation with the children i mean
that's on our side much more difficult
over the last 21 days cbp reportedly
encountered 435 unaccompanied children
every single day up from the previous
average
of about 340. they are staying in
facilities
for 107 hours on average longer than the
72 permitted
under u.s law a week ago ken the average
time was 77 hours
we're going far north of that what is
happening
well and you can expect that number to
keep going up harris
now by comparison we were down around 24
hours
when we got arms around the last crisis
in may of 2019
and they're they're going the wrong way
they're going the other way
and there truly aren't facilities there
was amazing to watch jen
saki say yeah we don't have the
facilities to hold these kids but it's
not a crisis
all in the same breath and and they
can't do
catch and release with children it's the
one group of people the unaccompanied
children
you can't just turn out onto the
sidewalk in your introductory report you
noted how many thousands of them are
even
under 12 years old so the strategy of
the families has come up to the border
shove their kids across which in america
would be considered child
neglect here our federal government
cooperates as the next chain in the
human smuggling operation
and that's if they come with adults that
they know but we're finding out about
you know they have these colored
bracelets the mexican drug cartels the
daily mail reuters doing
reports on this human smugglers are
using a system of colored wristbands
with information on the bracelets to
represent a multitude of data
used for smuggling organizations they
know whether or not they were paid for
coming across so an adult on the
southern part of the border had to pay
or what affiliation with smuggling
groups uh
they might be i mean this is so
dangerous for the kids one last word on
that and then i want to move
oh absolutely yeah and chip roy talked
about this congressman chip roy you've
got mexican officials speaking
anonymously now about how dangerous this
is and we're going to see again it's
really going on we're just not testing
for it
the recycling of children across that
border by the cartels
this is a bonanza for the most vicious
evil organizations in the western
hemisphere the mexican drug cartels who
do control that border
you know um the technology i i was just
talking about
of course that's the incentive that
mexico says that it's worried about now
and and just talk to us a little bit
about how different the relationship
is already with our southern neighbor
you know
former president trump had gotten a
place where if you're seeking asylum you
stayed there
south of our border in mexico and now
mexico is saying
wow this this is becoming a big business
in their country to smuggle especially
with those wristbands they can tell
who's paid and who hasn't
yeah it's a it's a full intelligence
network and the cartels and
enacted new business business procedures
because that's how they view it
um when joe biden was sworn in because
they could get away with it and they
knew it because
joe biden told them that publicly
i mean you can look all the way back for
months and months this has been coming
and in fact they were gearing up before
he was sworn in
mexico's president said this is
unsustainable
as reuters reported and this is
not doing anything positive for our
neighbors to the south
president trump got to through sort of
tough negotiating but got to some
very strong partnerships strong
cooperation the best we've ever had
with the northern triangle countries of
guatemala honduras and el salvador
as well as mexico and you described the
role mexico played harris very
accurately
and that was critical because when
migrants knew
that if they came up here illegally they
would have to stay in mexico
it dampened their order to come up
illegally substantially and the numbers
plummeted
in what is best referred to as the trump
effect we're now seeing
the biden effect what an invitation to a
whole bunch of illegals will do
is is flood the border and that's
exactly what's happening
and it's going to continue to get worse
these this is early in the season harris
this is normally the peak of illegal
immigration comes much later in the year
when it starts to really get warm we do
know that it must be frustrating for
those of you who worked so hard on this
to watch it
being unraveled now and even some
members of the administration high up
are saying well
you know they are coming because of the
policies they they feel like they'll
have a better chance now
ken thank you very much appreciate your
time and good to be with you harris